peacock which is the exclusive home of
the office by the way
uh every single episode right here on
peacock when we are done whatever you
want to do you can check out the office
uh all the episodes um are are for your
viewing and the man who plays
todd packer for all those years in the
office uh
and our great friend back here on the
rich eisen show and his new film the
right one
available now in select theaters on
digital and demand on blu-ray and dvd
there's really no way
that you can avoid checking out david
kechner in the right one how are you
david
i'm great how are you better for talking
to you how i mean yes
so so i mean you know this is what i i
say to friends
whose team just suffered um in glorious
defeat
in in the championship um this is how
i'll start how are you
you know what i mean like you just
changed the inflection a little bit like
how are you
you know or and then i'll just leave the
door open to see where you go
from that david just disappointed
obviously
understanding um secondly
but even feeling you know less hurt
having won it last year
i mean as you as everyone knows it had
been 50 years
since our last win and without that
under your belt this would have been
completely crushing it was so surprising
and i didn't know
i wasn't you know i didn't investigate
enough to figure out what had gone wrong
early uh and you can tell me because
you've got all the experts it really had
to do with the offensive line and i'm
not taking credit away from tampa bay
but clearly the team that played last
sunday was not the team that played all
year
well i don't think the team that played
last sunday is a team that i've seen
on the field with mahomes in all three
of his years as a starter i mean it was
so
jarring to see to see so much go wrong i
mean it was
that was really off-putting to say the
least it was
uh it was like where's what what
happened what happened to our team
so i know you know the whole offensive
line got rearranged
one of the guys had not started all year
right yeah no look you know who the
expert is on this you know who to call
you know to call you know who's the
offensive line kansas city offensive
line expert who's the one who got the
entire offensive line to show up to big
slick
stone but believe me i reached out to
him i'm like what do you think
and he you know he was he was quietly
confident
um but he was also genuinely concerned
you know because
he knows that uh you know trying to put
some trying to put that line together
you know in two weeks is not going to be
easy let alone against the box
yeah you can't do it you can't do it
clearly we couldn't do it
i just thought we were sluggish we were
flat
even the offense even beyond the
offensive line everyone seemed flat
and you tell me because you've got the
years of experience
having an organizational mishap
before such a big game do you do you
think that really affects the
organization i mean you know and you're
you're referring to
again what happened with andy reid's son
and brit reed and
you know i mean it doesn't matter what
your profession is and no matter how
focused you might be on the task at hand
your son has put a child in the hospital
in an accident that involves uh you know
alcohol
and you allegedly you know and and
you know and andy reed is one of the
best humans that you've that you've ever
met
he can't be he can't be all there i mean
that's a fact
you know what i mean so you put it
together what it does to the whole
organization you remember
years ago i forget what year it was the
first time atlanta had ever been in the
super bowl
and i forget the the quarterback's name
had been out and got arrested for
solicitation right yeah you're talking
about eugene robinson
and barrett robbins those were a falcon
and a raider respectively
uh right before yeah the raiders against
the uh the bucks
uh right in that first buccaneer super
bowl when
barr robbins went to mexico the night
before he was a starting center
i mean that's insane oh that's what it
was it was a center
yes and then eugene robinson he won the
man of the year award and then got
arrested the night before the super bowl
as well
so and then yeah i thought well that
that game's over before began
it's entirely possible but you know
where did you watch the game where did
you watch the super bowl in my house
okay yeah i didn't travel i was just at
my house with my family and
uh you know anticipating a great game
and then right away it wasn't and um
boy that was tough you know it's like
wait wait we got three
okay we got three i'm happy about it and
you know uh
uh steve um
young said at the end of the game he
said if you're kicking field goals
you're losing
yeah you know david i i totally agree
with that
but uh i gotta just call you out if you
don't mind i mean we go way back david i
just got to call you out that's that's
the wrong network to watch after a game
uh david
you know i was i
it's okay it's okay it's okay if
i was you don't have choices watching
you
all morning before the game until they
cut the coverage to
greatest super bowls then i went over to
channel two okay and then i will say
i didn't i was too depressed to even
to even oh you know what the nfl
afterward didn't they have just uh
graphics no no that's okay david i
wasn't on it afterwards
i went back and forth it's okay i did
it's all right but at some point
maybe later after the game i think i
just kind of walked away
and left it on the channel and just
walked around and you know what i know i
got on the phone with several friends
and we were doing our own uh dissection
of what happened
david it's okay you were disoriented you
didn't think that the chiefs would be
held without a touchdown i understand
that you were just it was out of body
and so you just made the wrong choice
and
that's okay it's okay but i just had to
point that out
like what do we do you know they in uh
the ancient
greek yes to sin
means to miss the mark and so
in in that it's an archer's term it's an
archer's term
it's a sin you miss the mark so guess
what
readjust try better next time that's it
super bowl 56 it's just around the
corner david you never you know what i
mean like see
oh no you'll know you'll know that
there's you know you were wearing a blue
pinstripe suit a
you don't have to say that if you just i
totally trust it you watch the pregame
show i totally trust
and that you do know that we were we we
did leave about 50 minutes before
kickoff and did put on alternate
programming on
you you're you're you're a good friend i
just needed to just i just
i'm sorry it was sort of a knee-jerk
reaction right there
you know what and friends can get
through those things
because i you don't hold the resentment
i'm not going to hold a resentment those
are the things that kill a marriage and
as far as i'm concerned you're the
closest thing i have to america
david keckner here on the rich hasn't
shown just to see that there's not a
problem between the two of us
let's talk about your new project david
let's talk
[Laughter]
tell me tell me about the right one tell
me about it
the right one is the right movie for
the week we know that we're coming up on
valentine's day
this sunday and what better way to
prepare than watching
a romantic comedy story nick soon
and cleopatra coleman if there ever was
a great name for a leading lady
i i think it's hard to best cleopatra
she is lovely and talented and
uh her her on-screen partner nick thune
is
funny and smart and i guess handsome i
don't
i don't weigh in on those things i'm not
i'd run a problem with it i just
i i really don't know just you have to
stay in your lane
i understand exactly um i assume if
you're the lead you're probably
good looking yes anyway nick's very
funny i've known him for years he's a
stand-up
uh i believe this is his first starring
role and i was doing what was i doing i
was doing bless this mess the television
show
and he called and said he listened
kenmock wrote and is directing this
movie he wants you and i said well
i'm doing the show i can't do it and he
said we can probably shoot you out over
a weekend
i'm like well okay so then i flew up
uh did all my stuff over the weekend and
then flew back to
the television show so who don't want to
shoot a movie right rich
of course and you are also a good friend
there there
there is an eye on david but you're a
team player you're here promoting it
you're promoting it you're doing you're
going the extra mile you're you're
taking
water you're taking time out of your
work like you could have ducked me you
could abduct me
you know because because no no no listen
you could have called into steve young's
show if he had one and made
made that call
i should get past it i'm sorry no but
you're you're taking time here
you're taking time out of your wednesday
after
i'm sorry um so
it's it's a fun movie uh uh uh nick
plays a bunch of different characters
i play a boss uh not
not breaking new ground here folks for
hector you're gonna go yep that's what
he does
and so but it was fun and uh you know
like that uh
i get to do a press tour i get to talk
to you uh we gotta talk some cheese so
i'm i'm i'm
very excited and i again not to correct
you again nick thune has had a starring
role before
and it's because we put him on the mound
in
safeco uh up in his beloved seattle
uh he taught he came on this show years
ago
talked about how he would love to throw
out a first pitch with the mariners he's
knocked on their door
they haven't basically let him do it we
did it for him
he got up there he showed up in like a
full
baseball uniform stirrups and everything
and he fired a strike sir
he had a big yes nick thune at a big
moment yes wow that's a fact so he was a
huge he was a huge fan of baseball
he is a he is a die-hard seattle sports
fan
like okay out of his mind about it wow
wow wow okay well good for him i thought
he got i'm glad he got to throw that
pitch he did
um he did so we know him he's a good
dude you're right he's a good dude he's
very funny
i like him so i'm glad he got this
opportunity for this pitch
and we'll see if he uh he comes up with
a strike or a home run
this week david keckner here on the rich
eisen show a couple things here
uh since we last spoke um the
we had the director of batman
um and uh and tenet on
for money the you know the doc
christopher nolan
i asked him what his remote drop movie
was and he had never heard the term
remote drop before
and i had to explain to him it's like no
matter where you see the film
on your television set you have to drop
the remote and watch it to the
conclusion
would you guess which i asked him what
his remote drop movie
was and he said talladega nights
it's okay that is the appropriate
reaction it is the appropriate reaction
yes
that's what he said that would not have
been
yeah i assumed since you were bringing
up to me that it was going to be
a picture that i was in yeah um you're
not
you're not in talladega nights yeah yeah
yeah right exactly
when you were leading there i was trying
to think of what movie that i'm in that
he
might like would that have been one of
the last ones
that would have been not not that would
have been among the bottom well i guess
i don't know i've been in quite a few so
at bottom bottom 20
yeah he said it was ricky the
the ballot of ricky bobby talladega
knights is what he said
and we you could have knocked us over
with a feather
and even he even said that if you're not
first you're lost like with his english
accent like he was james bond it was
phenomenal oh my god that's awesome
you never know who you're gonna you're
gonna impress david
never ever know you know you know it's
true years ago
i was um uh up for i guess some
online nike ad and i didn't even know it
right um but they were i know it was so
the
director told me the story they were
considering four or five actors
and um he wasn't quite sure who he
wanted to go with and he happened to be
in the middle of this is when there were
dvds watching uh season three or four
for what it was
of curb your enthusiasm yes and i pop on
the screen as joseph
in one of the uh episodes he goes oh my
god that guy
and it's so interesting how things
happen like that that's how i got that
job because he had watched it before
saw it again and go oh my god i like
that guy yes let's let's cast that guy
so who knows look out man move over
michael kane here comes david keckner in
the next christopher nolan movie
here do you got it mike if you ain't
first you laugh there it is that's what
he said
that's awesome it's fantastic yeah
you never know what little thing nudges
your opportunity one way or the other
uh you know some people i guess it is
networking i'm not
and i there's nothing wrong with it it's
just not in my nature to go and make
sure i'm
at all kinds of events where you know
you you glad-hand people that's fine
interesting that i'm a i was a poli-sci
major yet i
that doesn't seem to be in my blood but
um yeah
i guess my my strategy is to be in so
many things
i'm uh they're not going to miss me well
now uh
you know we're on nbc sports on peacock
peacock's the new exclusive home of the
office what's your favorite office that
you were in
uh david what's your favorite one gosh
darn it
sorry if you heard that that's my alarm
going off to remind me that i'm doing
your show 20 minutes ago
um well done seriously you got this
thing you got this thing wired david you
got this thing wired
[Laughter]
uh it's hard to say you know the one the
first one was
so much fun and it was only the first
season was only six episodes
and they were having trouble casting
that role
and um i was up in canada shooting
snakes on the plane thank you very much
you're all welcome
um and so i guess they they shot a lot
of that
episode and they knew they had to go
back to it and carell
said to greg daniels how about kechner
and so that's how i got the job
and so i went in there and i didn't give
it any i know i gave it thought as an
actor but you don't think about
and you consider the grace of things
like that that turn into something huge
a simple suggestion from a friend who
says
him they give you the job and there's a
certain freedom rich when they give you
a job
you go it's mine i'm gonna play it how i
want to play it
rather than oftentimes if you're
auditioning you know it should be the
same attitude
which is i'm gonna play it how i want to
play it but you do spend a healthy
amount of time
thinking i wonder what they're looking
for i hope i'm doing it how they want it
which doesn't serve you but when they
give it to you it's yours
so you just get to go play and so that
was so much fun and you know the
characters just
an awful human and the fun part of that
is
he says things that you could never say
to another human being without getting
punched in the face
so that's the delight and joy of that
thing so i hearken back to the first one
being
among my favorites the first one so
basically what you're saying is
champ kind led to todd packer is what
you're saying um well see i'd known
steve in a way yes okay because had i
not done
um anchorman i probably wouldn't have
had the
hollywood weight to just be offered the
roles yes although you know i've known
steve since 91
but then i might not have been on other
person's radars had that
film's success not uh not been so
prominent 91 when how did you meet him
then how did you guys come across the
same second second
chicago yeah it's amazing how many
people just go back to second city
colbert too right yeah right yep was he
there with
youtube they were in the same company uh
colbert and corel
and remember though they did those
hilarious fedex commercials for
a couple couple runs gosh and uh
they kind of popped on those because
they were so funny and they've got such
a great uh chemistry
and like that they had work they've done
several main stage shows
at second city so they'd worked together
for several years and then i forget if
they were both
on the daily show at that time uh i
can't remember but
wow um and then of course that may have
been pre-daily show but anyway
and then of course you've pulled on a
very uh close relationship to appear in
tick-tock videos these days too
uh correct david how old are you
how do your kids know 12
they are 12. soon to be 10 and seven and
there are there are tic tac there's a
new tick tock account for my two dogs
in my house okay so that's what's going
on so my daughter has though
my daughter has pulled me in judiciously
several times to do
participate in those with her and it's
interesting to me that you know she
she's not ravenous about it
they all love it and there's i you know
there's a psychological
i think they've done some studies of why
people
love tic toc so much because it's just
you're refreshing the whole thing
i think it's a constant stream of
dopamine but um
so every once in a while she goes dad
we're gonna do a tick tock okay you
ready
and you know i love how we we'll have to
shoot them three or four times because
my performance isn't good enough but
uh those are always a delight and that
you'll give me the updates of how many
views they have and how many likes and
how many comments and all that stuff
so is it the dance moves is that is that
the what we've determined is most
popular for you and your daughters
i don't know i think i think i've done
three i can't remember i know one was a
uh uh one was a recreation of a scene
from clueless
one was some recreation of a dinner
party
from the kardashians and one was some
trending dance moves and song
my moves are very limited
within the parameters of what i could uh
what i could do so um
basically you're doing the tick tock
because your daughter you get to do
something with your daughter and if
if you ain't if you're if he ain't first
your last and that
much whole situation this i love it man
i
you know i'm not i'm not you know then i
will get contacted by other people
wanting to do tick-tock collaboration
slippery slope it's a slippery slope
be careful that's what i'm saying no
have you done some with your kids
i have yet to do that um but uh i have
yet to be asked
uh but i will serve if asked i will do
it um
and yeah but you know and luckily it's
not a uh
it's not a frequent thing it's very
infrequent well i i look
for i look forward to it i look forward
to seeing more of it i'll keep an eye
out for it
uh the right is there an old person's
one now isn't it
is clubhouse the old person
no you got to get on the old clubhouse
stone street joined uh
one that i did over the weekend out of
the blue which is the first one
we the first one we ever did we we we
kind of like thelma and louise we
grabbed each other's hands and we
we we floored it on the clubhouse if you
ain't first you laugh thank you very
much well done
you laughed was he down in tampa
no he was not he was just he was at home
and just like
sheltered down and getting ready for the
big game and and i got
i got as soon as it was 21-6 i got a one
word text from him
well he said welp w-e-l-p that was it
so i know that myself and him
and riggle and uh sadakis
and rudd were on a group text together
and uh at one point he said okay let's
focus on the game
guys
[Laughter]
i love that he's just like
there was a 20-person dad text from one
of my kids schools
trying to set up a uh a squares
board and i'm like and they kept you
know saying you're in check
i'm not in i don't want to wish for a
number
i'm watching the game i'm focusing on
the game i don't strips
i don't want pools i don't want nothing
i'm rooting that's
it thanks for the call the right one
currently available in
uh select theaters on digital and demand
on blu-ray and dvd
thank you for the call i've always loved
chatting and by the way
chris brockman write it down for next
year as a possibility for
uh fantasy football constant stream of
dopamine
i love that as a team name i i think i
wrote that one down when you threw that
one out david thank you um
well i'll leave with this and i hope
it's not too soon to say
yes i adore you right back at you thank
you for the call okay baby you're right
hey buddy the one and only david keckner
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here